There is a Darkness coming
of all the threats
from both your past
Pull over! I'm not driving.
and future
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
this can't be real. okay it's real.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this will be my Transformers rise
of the Beast trailer video this is going to be
Transformers doing their version of Beast Wars
a lot of you having flashbacks to your childhood
a lot of Easter eggs here so I'll explain what's
going on because they're combining some aspects
of the Beast Wars lore with what they've already
done in the newer Transformers movies like
Transformers Bumblebee if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos I will do more videos for the
movie if we get more footage more details about
what's actually going on with the future of the
Transformers films but it just seems like based on
the designs of the Transformers they're actually
carrying forward in the Bumblebee timeline and
this is said in the 90s so just about a decade
after the events of the Bumblebee film and that's
why Bumblebee Optimus Prime looked the exact same
that they did in that previous movie here's where
they start to combine stuff because obviously you
have the maximals in the Predacons interacting
with the modern day Transformers originally
during the Beast Wars cartoon they explained that
it was sort of like a redesign of the entire toy
line and they were meant to be the descendants
of the original Autobots intercepticons some
of you also probably detected the Easter egg
for the three main groups in the title scene 2
so in the title of the trailer the logo in the
the Transformer's word flips three times first
it's the traditional Autobots to represent their
characters in the present day of the movie in the
90s this is the maximals logo from the Beast Wars
TV series and this is the terracons logo who are
going to be like the villains of the film so like
this main character is Optimus primal and he's the
descendant of Optimus Prime and he uses that name
as a way to honor the original Optimus Prime but
they're together in the same scenes during this
movie there was a later cartoon that was meant
to be a sequel to Beast Wars called Beast Machines
which explained the process by which the autobots
and the Decepticons evolved into these forms
the maximals and the Predacons they call that
the great upgrade and it was meant to be like
a big transformation of their species but the
whole idea with Transformers they've established
previously in the lore is that when they go to new
planets they try to adapt to whatever forms are
most common there which is why they transform into
cards when they land on planet Earth the way they
explain that great upgrade during the Beast Wars
cartoon is that the inner John was so rich on the
planet they went to is that they couldn't stay in
their traditional transfer former's forms for that
long and had to change in two beasts what it seems
like they've done here though is that they're
explaining that these versions of the Beast Wars
characters are actually just previous versions
of the Transformers characters that were on Earth
long before this so is their way of doing all the
animal themed Transformers but also incorporating
some of the terracons which includes some of the
Dinobots characters which is another huge cut
for the classic Transformers cartoons they kind
of did a version of those characters during the
Michael Bay films but the whole idea with this new
line of Transformers continuity starting with the
Bumblebee movie is that Michael Bay isn't involved
with any of it so it's kind of like a soft reboot
of the Transformers franchise but the terracons
are meant to be a different group of Decepticons
that sort of broke off and they transform
into monsters specifically and act as their
own separate group they were featured during the
Dinobots story arc back during gen 1 Transformers
Magnus walked I've never seen Decepticons as
vicious as those monstrous Terror guns lucky
we have the texture Bots yeah but those
high-tech heroes are in for one horrific
battle out of monsters Terracon beasts comes
the incredible abominus futuristic computron
so they're bringing together the Beast Wars
cartoon with their modern day bumblebee timeline
continuity which is why all the characters are
able to interact together instead of them being
the descendants of the original Transformers
some of the previous continuity they're carrying
forward like you have Optimus Prime talking to
Optimal Primal who's obviously the gorilla his
design is meant to be an Easter egg for King Kong
but previously they've explained the whole concept
of the primes Optimus primal is one of the other
primes like Optimus Prime so during this moment in
the trailer where they meet each other it seems
like they have a bit of a standoff is sort of
a standoff of the primes two leaders obviously
on the same side that come to terms like oh we
need to help each other because of this coming
Darkness becoming darkness that they talk about
in the trailer or the big fights you see later
when things escalate are probably the terror
cons Optimus primal is going to be voiced by Ron
Perlman you know him from like a thousand other
things I know people will be asking questions
about Megatron because there was a version of
Megatron during Beast Wars but it was meant to
be the descendant of the original Megatron he
was a Tyrannosaurus Rex and he was just using
the name as a way to honor the previous one
so they'll streamline some of that continuity so
that it makes sense for the actual films this is
what Optimus primal looks like in his robot mode
wielding these two swords he's meant to be really
really big most of the way a lot of these Beast
Wars characters work are meant to be Easter eggs
for that original cartoon the orange and black tow
truck is named battle trap there was a version of
a duocon from the Gen 1 Transformers named battle
trap but I think they might just be using the name
for this version of the character he's meant to
be one of the members of this new faction the
terracons that Optimus primal is talking about
when he mentions the coming Darkness RC and will
Jack are back they made a brief appearance during
the Bumblebee movie now she's transforming into
a red and white motorcycle the VW bus is wheel
Jack not sure what's happening in this wide shot
here but it's probably them just exploring more of
the lore and Optimus primal explaining more about
what's coming more about the terracons and they
use it for another big info dump the giant cheetah
here running with bumblebee is chidor it gives
you a good idea of the scale like I said bumblebee
keeping his same kamero form for from the
Bumblebee movie just to help you with the timeline
like oh this is part of the same continuity
just a little bit of time has gone by they
kind of teased this movie at the end of the first
bumblebee movie when he met up with Optimus Prime
this is meant to be cheater's robot mode he has
this Wolverine looking claws this giant Falcon
Transformer is one of the maximals called a razor
voiced by Michelle yo the big rhinoceros is named
rhinox who's voiced by David sabalov then I think
we all believe that this is meant to be Mirage
because of the way he uses his ability creating a
bunch of copies of the Porsche form that he takes
he's another classic gen 1 Transformer but
I believe he was an F1 car back in the 1980s
this is a new character grabbing bumblebee here
isn't meant to be Nemesis Prime this is actually
a version of scourge voiced by Peter Dinklage he's
the leader of the terracons during this this other
dark faction that's coming to take them all his
other form is this road warrior looking semi truck
like they want to give him this dark Optimus Prime
vibe there actually was an evil clone version of
Optimus Prime during the robots in Disguise
cartoon this is another one of the terracons
called nightbird there was a gen 1 Night bird that
was a ninja built for Dr Fujiyama in the movie She
transforms into a black sports car with the purple
hubcaps during in the big battle scenes there's a
bunch of really quick blink and you'll miss it
Transformers in the background like really tiny
ones might just wind up being cannon fodder for
a lot of the big action scenes even though hailee
steinfeld's character doesn't appear anywhere
during this she could always come back into the
franchise I don't know if she's supposed to have
a cameo during the film at all just because she's
got so much stuff going on in the Marvel Universe
now but it sounds like what they're trying to say
is that since the events of the first film The
Beast Wars characters have awakened like they've
been in hibernation for millions of years and
whatever caused them to be awakened also alerted
the terracons and the terracons are the ones that
are coming to planet Earth but if you spotted any
other Easter eggs in the trailer or any other big
Transformers characters that I didn't talk about
they have questions about just write it below
in the comments we'll get a couple more trailers
early next year the next real big thing that's
coming up is Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
with Kang there'll be a bunch more trailers
for that in the next couple of weeks because
movies coming out in February it's deceptively
quiet right now like there's a bunch of chaos
happening with DC movies but there is a bunch of
big movie related stuff coming up between Marvel
DC in the early part of next year the Transformers
rise of the Beast movie isn't coming out till
summer so it's going to be a little while before
that hits everyone click here for my Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 trailer video and click here for
my Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!